Did you know,
Philly residents eat 12 times more pretzels
than your average American?
That's twisted.
(laughing)
That's pretty salty.
It doesn't work as well as yours Rossy.
Well, that's your fun snack fact for the road,
and think of it as an appe-teaser
to today's Philly installment of "The Doggy Bag".
(music)
(Barking)
Here to curate, we've got a Philly based beauty expert
and you can keep up with her and
design tips every day on Instagram at
Beauty For Breakfast,
please welcome, Dana Oliver.
Yeah.
Beauty for breakfast.
Hello, Drew.
Hello, Ross.
Hi , Dana.
I'm so excited that I'm the doggy bag,
but guess what?
I've got a treat for you.
(Barking)
So it's from my favorite local small business,
black owned brand that I love to shop for.
It's my go-to for beauty and wellness products.
And you know,
what I love most about Marsh and Mane is that,
it has the latest, greatest,
even the big and small brands that you know,
you may find in your big box retailers
or ones that you've never heard of.
And on the table here,
I've got one of my favorite products.
It is their hair and body butter.
And I can't resist a butter.
By the way,
I read that this was your favorite product and now we get
to try it?
You get to try it, I brought four yummy scents.
You have the sweet sandalwood
which has a nice warm musky scent.
You have the nag champa,
which is just, you know.
Trade me. - Dude you have to smell this.
You are gonna die the sandalwood.
And here is Jasmine.
Oh!
It smells yummy, right?
Let me, let me.
Smell, smell, smell them all.
Oh my God, you guys.
And touch and feel it's non-greasy.
And what I love most about this product is that you can use
it from head to toe.
Dana, You're such a beautiful woman inside and out,
and we're so excited that you would grace us with your
presence on the show.
I think your recommendation is so solid.
Marsh and Mane looks like the most extraordinary
Haven for beauty junkies.
Thank you so much.
It was such an honor to be in this fabulous city today.
And thank you everyone for joining us here at Love Park and
everybody watching at home or on the go or wherever you are.
We hope that we get to see you again really soon.
And again, everybody who decided to hang out
and spend a little time today.
Thank you.
We know you could be anywhere doing anything.
Thanks for hanging out with us.
We hope you have fantastic day.
Yay!
Now I'm gonna finish this sandwich.
Look at her.